[Música]
sí
y
i
buenas noches buenas tardes perdón está
oscuro acá aparece de noche vos sabes
que antes de venir para acá venía
caminando de la nada chicas pero de la
nada y me gritaron [ __ ] y 88 por lo
menos no me gritaron gordas
si esto es un tema esto es un tema
porque viste que nunca falta la que
viene y te dice hay pasajes porque esos
guardas porque no sabes comer me estás
jodiendo boluda imagínate si no supiera
no
y ustedes vieron que están las
protectoras de las ballenas como
greenpeace bueno yo soy gorda protectora
gremialista piquetera patotera defensora
de las calzas que te marcan el papo
ahora todo metal mirando el papel
me puede dejar de mirar el papá de como
el de tu novio un poquito más gordo nada
porque evite que la gorda no solamente
tenemos papás sino que también tenemos
ante papá porque somos más completa el
único problema que yo tengo acá en
córdoba es que cuando vos querés cruzar
rápido rápido rápido la calle y cruzar
con la calza siempre hay un taxista
forma que te grita apúrate gorda papuda
apud así y gorda no sé en qué te basas
no aparte te aviso que si me atropelle
este culo no tiene segura
quiero saber esta tarde si alguna gorra
popular que levante la mano
1 2 3 4 y el resto que son pampita sofía
zámolo alcolea humana son todas flaca
dios sabe que es todo un tema la vida de
la gorda porque es todo un tema la gorda
y la calza no porque viste que está la
gorda que usa la calza negra porque ella
pretende disimular algo pero está la
gorda más riesgo la que usa la calza
floreada con margarita que el culo
parecen girasoles nada
y ya sabes que viene ahora es una gorda
entrar a un shopping yo cuando entró un
shopping es como que las escaleras
mecánicas se comunican entre sí y se
empiezan a avisar gorda por la puerta
principal gorda por la puerta principal
gorda por la prenda principal y que
hacen dejan de funcionar y yo qué hago
me voy por el ascensor enemigo principal
de la gorda porque cuando llegas hay un
cartel gigante que dice 300 kilos o 4
personas máximo yo solita peso la mitad
y cuando llego hay dos placas esperando
para subir y me ven llegar y se hacen
las buenas me dice no nos subimos o las
subimos holanda toda la junta vamos a ir
todas juntas como en un mantra y van
rezando que se bajen primero la que se
imprime la gorda no viajéis su imagen
estuvimos en su viaje 14 veces hasta que
llega al cuarto físicas y me cago
boxeando con la vendedora porque cuando
llegue le dije tenía lo que me entre si
me dijo un par de aro una bufanda
de [ __ ]
gracias
todo un tema es todo un tema a la gorda
y las redes sociales de levante dice que
está muy de moda team there happen lo
tienen y yo en estas redes sociales de
levante como que te soy más humilde y te
lleva las fotos las hubo de acá para acá
y estaba chateando lo tenía con un
chongo y me hice mar con también algo
más de voz me dice porque no se ve mucho
en la foto me dice como como sos me
dices
simpáticas nada me dice cómo hacer este
físicamente a rellenitas definirme
rellenita me dijo no no no me hice vamos
al grano cuánto pesa que cuánto pesa
mira flaco no pregunté pero tú ese curso
no te pregunto cuánto te mide la [ __ ]
y así quizás de esta manera quizás de
esta manera pude cubrir tantos
prejuicios sociales a lo largo de toda
mi vida pude tapar el dolor con un poco
de humor y sin dudas mi monólogo de hoy
tiene el título mi mano luego debe no sé
cómo se usó esto no eso toda nueva
memoria lo que se llama gorda sin tener
el título que he venido pero no hay está
ahí también estaba viendo mi bayas
estaba gorda y la verdad es que sufrí
mucho bullying y muchas discriminaciones
a lo largo de mi vida sí pero no vine a
victimizar me vine a contarles una
historia muy linda y cuando era chica
el bullying más fuerte que sufrí lo
sufrí en la infancia cuando tenía más o
menos 67 años y mi papá me espera la
puerta del colegio este es mi papá me
iba para ver su amor vido pesaba 350
kilos y andaba en esa moto no caminaba y
lo más fuerte era salido del colegio y
verlo ahí en esa moto
saben lo que es para un niño de 6 años
ver a una persona tan gorda más en un
pueblo era como el gordo del circo él
era gordo y yo también era gorda bueno
hubiera sido siendo éramos gordos los
dos entonces el bullying
y recaía doblemente no por mi papá y por
mí y logró que me lastimaba tanto pero
tanto que lastimen a mi héroe que a
veces me avergonzaba de que me vais a
buscar a la puerta del colegio y esta
parte me emociona un montón
entonces me escondía en la garita del
portero me escondía y los veía salir a
mis compañeros y yo quería salir última
para que no me vean con él y mientras yo
lo veía reírse de mi papá me daba
muchísimas ganas de agarrar una
ametralladora y matarlos a todos los que
se reían y la verdad que tenía 6 años no
iba a conseguir ametralladora ni en pedo
en este momento
pero pasaron los años y quizás los
insultos no disminuyeron no me armaron
siempre va a estar la discriminación en
la persona con obesidad quizás yo le di
menos importancia y la verdad que si me
tendría que poner a matar a todas las
personas que me insultaron a lo largo de
mi vida no me alcanzarían las balas así
que decidí matarlos pero de la risa por
eso soy humorista por eso hago minas
jodidas y voy a viajar por todo el país
llevando alegría a miles de personas que
alguna vez se sintieron como yo sí y me
di cuenta me di cuenta que en este tema
de la discriminación si no solamente son
discriminadas las personas obesas
lamentablemente argentina es uno de los
países más gordos fóbicos del mundo pero
no solamente discrimina las personas
gordas se discrimina a las personas con
discapacidades diferentes a las personas
homosexuales las chicas trans
difícilmente consiga trabajo diferente
en alguna empresa porque este país
la verdad es muy prejuiciosa
y les quiero contar el monólogo del papá
que lo hice primero si es un monólogo
que es un poquito más largo yo lo
resumía acá y se reirá muchísimo a gente
del país con este monólogo y les quiero
contar porque lo escribí yo tenía 18
años estaba estudiando en córdoba
estudia ciencias económicas aunque no
crean esta cuestión de ciencias
económicas y había empezado tenis iba
tenis y la verdad es que me cagaba de
calor en las clases de tenis porque era
verano hacían 40 grados y yo jugaba con
jogging frisado no porque me daba
muchísimo vergüenza mostrar mis piernas
de verdad era muy cuenta la típica gorda
tímida vergonzosa y estaba en la cancha
de tenis jugando con mucho calor el
profesor se me acerque me hice mar veo
que la pasas mal me dice no tenés que
venir con esos pantalones recontra
calurosos así que me hice la próxima
clase si no venís con la pollera de
tenista no vas a jugar al tenis jereije
ni en pedo muestra las piernas y él me
dijo sácate el prejuicio de la cabeza
como si el prejuicio fuera mío
la cuestión es que mi profesor era muy
determinante y de verdad si no conseguí
esa dichosa pollera no podía volver a la
cancha de tenis
la cuestión es que me fui de la clase de
tenis pensando me fui a buscar polleras
estuve una semana por todo córdoba
buscando el apoyo la talle doble xl la
que nunca conseguí en ningún lado decidí
mandarme la hacer con una modista y
cuando logré tener la pollera pasaron
dos semanas de haber faltado a la clase
de tenis y dos semanas de tratar de
convencer de ponerme esa pulsera no
desde salir al mundo mostrar mis piernas
mostrar mi celulitis me dije más si me
chupa un huevo la gente me será superada
agarre
a la noche anterior de la clase de tenis
tenía las piernas tan blancas que me
puse autobronceante chico me puse
autorizante de acá para caer anamá
ferreira de acá para cada planta acá te
está encima me manche todas las manos
dejé manchada la sábana no lo hagan en
sus casas si la cuestión es que al otro
día me puse la pollera agarró de la
raqueta y salí a la vida y cuando llegó
cuando llegó a la esquina solamente a la
esquina de mi casa con la pollera de
tenis
quise cruzar el semáforo recién se ponía
en rojo
un paso un taxista rápidamente y me
gritó corriente gorda papuda a lo que yo
hice tres pasos para atrás me vuelve el
cordón y me evolucionando a mi casa
tenía 18 años en ese momento estaba
pasando una crisis muy grande porque
había muerto mi papá y la verdad que
estaba muy deprimida y yo había buscado
en el tenis una forma de despejar me de
no deprimir medio encerrarme en mi casa
comer no y siempre digo wow el poder de
las palabras yo dejé tenis por un
[ __ ] que me dijo gorda para pura que
solamente vio que soy gorda pero no sabe
cuan papuda soy porque no estuvo conmigo
no entonces digo cómo puede ser que yo
haya dejado tenis algo que me encantaba
y el poder de las palabras yo me acuerdo
todos los días de mi vida de ese taxista
en todos los show que hago de minas
jodidas pero en el fondo le agradezco
porque hoy yo hago minas jodidas por
todo el país escribiendo monólogos de
cosas que me hicieron sufrir como cosas
que me dijeron mis ex como cosas que me
dijo este taxista y luego lo que me fue
bárbaro gane muchísima plata me preguntó
si él sigue manejando un taxi yo ahora
maneja una bmc de querer matar el parque
así que ya está
y
y me di cuenta que la obesidad es una
enfermedad socialmente aceptada a ser
burlada y discriminada nadie se va a
burlar de una persona con cáncer y le
van a decir correcta daca cancerígeno de
[ __ ] pero si sólo vas a decir una
persona gorda porque lamentablemente
tenemos tan podrido a la sociedad que
creemos que el gordo siempre tiene que
ser el eje de las risas no al gordo está
bien a una persona con cáncer no los
chicos a nadie ni con cáncer ni gordo ni
personas con discapacidad ni
homosexuales ni lo que sea si eso es lo
que quiero dejar claro en esta charla y
en mis campañas que vengo haciendo a lo
largo de hace un montón de tiempo decidí
hablarles a las personas que sufrieron
lo mismo que yo las personas que alguna
vez se sintieron mal o discriminadas o
que no entran dentro de los cánones de
belleza sí y la verdad es que empecé a
enseñarles a que nosotras las personas
gordas tenemos derecho a usar pollera a
mostrar las piernas a ponernos short
aire la pileta a usar malla una de las
grandes campañas que hice a nivel
nacional fue la campaña de mi foto en
maya incentive a que miles de personas
gordas vayan al río vayan a la
porque hace calor y porque lo necesitan
y porque la gente quieren que les diga
algo siempre va a hablar siempre se va a
burlar le enseñes a gente a amarse a
respetarse valorarse y sobre todo a
reírse de uno mismo saben por qué por
como uno se ríe de sí mismo se hace más
fuerte se hace más valiente si yo me río
primero de mi misma la burla del boludo
a que él ya no tiene sentido
la burla ya perdió gracia porque yo
primero me río de mí entonces él va a
buscar de molestar a alguien que
realmente le haga daño y quieren que les
digo una cosa a la gente siempre van a
encontrar en todos lados lamentablemente
gente que se vaya a burlar de ustedes
siempre pero ustedes lo tienen que tomar
de como quien viene de gente fracasada
que lamentablemente necesita burlarse de
otros para sentirse un poquito más
importante en su vida entiendan los que
no lograron nada nada de su vida sí y
bueno básicamente me cuestionan mucho de
con esto de fomentar el amor propio no
les enseño a que se amen a que se
perdonen a que se miren al espejo y
abracen su cuerpo
y saben por qué les enseñó amar su
cuerpo ni por gordas
flacas saben por qué porque es el único
cuerpo que van a tener y van a tener que
aprender a amarlo a pesar de la
circunstancia a pesar de que no sea el
cuerpo de revista y basta de guiarse del
cuerpo de revista ese cuerpo lleno de
photoshop solamente existen las revistas
si ese cuerpo que representan los medios
solamente representan un 5% de la
sociedad el otro 95 no es eso si ojo no
está mal pero dejemos de pudrir los a la
cabeza a los adolescentes con cuerpos
incansables porque nunca llegan a ese
cuerpo lleno de photoshop la vida real
no es una foto de portada de la revista
caras la vida real es lo que ustedes
están viendo en este preciso momento
quieres enseñar a mis gordos carlos que
me sigan les enseñará a ser gordos
alegres porque muchos me dijeron los
gordos no pueden ser alegres porque no
se pueden mover por la diabetes por esto
por aquello por las enfermedades que
acarrea la obesidad es verdad acarreo
enfermedades por eso tienen que cuidar
sus cuerpos pero saben cuál es la
enfermedad más grave que acarrea la
obesidad los prejuicios sociales
que quedan en el alma los que te quedan
para toda la vida porque el colesterol
alto se puede curar porque puedes bajar
de peso pero nunca te vas a olvidar de
ese taxista boludo que te grite te grito
corriente gorda papuda no entonces
porque les enseñó a hacer gordos alegres
porque el tema de ser feliz fue algo que
se los quitó la sociedad adonde está
escrito que los gordos no pueden ser
alegres adonde está escrito que no
pueden ser felices es una norma acaso no
hago este escrito es un gordo no se
puede querer y aceptarse y amarse como
es y saben porque los quiero alegres
porque cuando una persona empieza a
engordar el autoestima empieza a bajar y
la depresión empieza a aumentar y todo
eso da igual a más engorde a medida que
aumenta la depresión voy a seguir
engordando porque los quiero felices
porque los quiero positivos porque un
gordo positivo y feliz va a tener ganas
de calzarse las zapatillas ir al
gimnasio ir a bailar zumba pasarla bien
divertirse y querer cuidar su cuerpo una
persona deprimida lo único que va a
lograr es seguir destruyendo sé que
muchas veces me han preguntado cómo
podemos ayudar a las personas obesas
porque muchos sobre todas las redes
sociales que son todos opinólogos muchos
te dicen gorda cerrar la boca y move el
[ __ ] y va a saber cómo vas a bajar de
peso si fuera tan fácil yo voy a que
tendrá que ser pampita no porque probé
muchísimos métodos para bajar de peso y
la verdad es que no funcionaron y la
verdad que si tiene una persona que está
pasando una situación así y le quieren
dar un consejo tienen un consejo desde
una buena experiencia sabes que el primo
del vecino de paula empezó un gimnasio
que está genial no sabes todo lo que
bajó de peso está divina siempre
comenten leer una linda experiencia pero
no le den una orden si me lo prometen
y la verdad es que la mujer que soy hoy
al amar nueva que soy hoy que creció que
fue afrontando los prejuicios le
encantaría que la salida de esta
universidad esté su papá esperándola en
su motito no ir corriendo abrazarlo
fuerte y no tener que matarlos todos
ustedes
y la verdad que le pido perdón al cielo
por esa nena de 6 años que se siente
avergonzada por él de verdad y también
le quiero contar que cuando era chica en
mi pueblo en mi barrio en la esquina
había unos chicos que siempre se
juntaban y me arman de la mui petista y
yo era muy gorda
entonces nos había dicho una canción
para las dos que ellos se burlaban y se
divertían mucho pero hasta el día de hoy
que el acuerdo y la canción decía medio
metro
la hermana de temblor no se le van a
olvidar más a la canción chicos en taxis
si a medio metro a la hermana de temblor
cuando pasa por la calle tiembla todo
alrededor ella leal a medio metro porque
era petista y yo obvio era la temblor y
siempre digo que esos chicos tenían
razón pero se quedaron cortos porque no
soy un temblor
soy un terremoto pero de actitud por eso
ahora quiero que pasen dónde están todas
mis chicas si pueden ir pasando
que se lo pague quiero que pasen todas
esas invite a un par de amigas un fuerte
aplauso para ellos para recibirlas
chica me taparon la pantalla leer lee lo
que dice atrás
que dice no más fuerte más fuerte gorda
no es un insulto les quedó claro un
fuerte aplauso para mis modelos que
vinieron hoy
[Aplausos]
gracias
aprendamos
aprendamos a respetar la diversidad de
cuerpos cada uno es como es cada uno
nadie va a ser igual al otro amen se
quieran se cuiden se y dejen de decir
que los gordo no nos cuidamos porque te
puedo asegurar que no hay un gordo que
se levante todos los días de su vida
pensando que hacer para mejorar su salud
es una enfermedad hoy no viene hablar de
la enfermedad como tal lamentablemente
en argentina todavía hay gente que
discute que la obesidad no es una
enfermedad es una enfermedad
lamentablemente sí así que bueno y
lamentablemente es una enfermedad con la
que más se curra en este en el tema
estético medicinal si ganan millones de
plata gracias a la obesidad y gracias a
que las obras sociales no cubren los
mejores tratamientos para bajar de peso
así que quiero saber chicos ustedes que
están acá ustedes que son gordas porque
hay muchos prejuicios acerca de las
gordas pueden bailar
pueden tener relaciones sexuales
ah bueno
[Aplausos]
se pueden atar los cordones
bueno eso para que vean que a pesar de
ser gordas podemos hacer un montón de
cosas pueden ser madres
bueno muchísimas gracias muchas gracias
los esperamos siquiera la salida a la
salida de la universidad no vamos a
sacar fotos todas las chicas en ropa
interior si de verdad para que se
empieza a normalizar la diversidad del
cuerpo no lo podemos hacer adentro de la
universidad pero afuera así así que si
nos quieren acompañar nos vemos gracias
bueno para qué
[Música]
y
i
[Música]